welcome back to cbs mornings when the
u.s pulled out of afghanistan last year
the biden administration made a
controversial decision to seize seven
billion dollars in assets from that
country's central bank half of the money
is earmarked earmarked to help the
afghan people and the other half is for
9 11 families seeking compensation but
now there's another group of terror
victims who say they should also get
some of that money our senior
investigative correspondent catherine
herridge has the story catherine good
morning
good morning tony in 2015 with
bipartisan support congress created a
fund to compensate terrorism victims
financed through fines and penalties
it's allocated more than three billion
dollars of claims but when the afghan
money was frozen the process was
different impacting hundreds of american
families
how many pieces of glass have been
removed over the years
probably 30 or 40.
77 year old bob essington recalls april
18 1983 as the day terror rained down on
the u.s embassy in beirut lebanon it was
a shock it was like a shock wave hit me
planted by an iranian back terror group
the 2 thousand pound truck bomb killed
63 and injured more than a hundred
nobody knew what it was at first but
then all of a sudden the impact the
explosive force compressed essington's
spine permanently impairing his mobility
i have a stimulator implanted in my hip
with 14 plates on my spine if i shut it
off i go into instant pain and there's
nothing to stop the pain
after the u.s pulled out of afghanistan
and froze 7 billion in assets from that
country central bank the essingtons
along with other families expected at
least some of the money would go to a
general compensation fund created by
congress to benefit u.s victims of
terrorism but president biden's
executive order earmarked three and a
half billion to support the urgent needs
of the people of afghanistan the
remaining three and a half billion was
left for a new york court to decide
compensation with a small group of 911
families with claims against the taliban
at the head of the line we're not going
to get anything for
what happened to us
you know it's like government doesn't
care anymore
how unusual is the president's executive
order on the afghan funds it's very
unusual
but the whole thing is unusual ken
feinberg has overseen more than 20
billion dollars in victims compensation
including claims by 9 11 families was
the u.s victims of terrorism fund a
viable option for the money absolutely
feinberg said the federal court was also
an option to handle victims claims but
no decision was without controversy
you're going to get frustration and
emotional
disagreement and anger no matter how you
distribute three and a half billion
dollars
victims of terrorist attacks in the 80s
and 90s against u.s embassies and
military installations sent this letter
with over 400 signatures to president
biden urging him to change course
writing the victims compensation fund
was created for exactly these moments
for the benefit of all u.s terrorism
victims not one small group the white
house told cbs news the administration
undertook extensive analysis on this
complex issue that factored in the
urgent need for afghan aid and victims
compensation adding the administration
could not simply transfer to the victims
fund
these programs
are more than just sort of taking a
calculator
and deciding who gets what
there's a very important element i
learned the hard way in the 911 fund
giving everybody a voice the marine got
blown from here essington a state
department and vietnam veteran rarely
speaks of the 1983 attack it's hard
to talk about what happened
why is it hard
i think it's because of all the friends
that i lost
now he wants president biden to
acknowledge his story i don't care about
the total amount that i get or anything
like that it's just his recognition
of us
the sacrifices that all of us made
and earlier this month more than 300
veterans and families wrote to house and
senate committees urging them to support
legislation that would redirect the
money to the victims fund and there's
another factor critics of the
president's executive order say it
punishes the afghan people who face a
humanitarian crisis and that all of the
money belongs to them gail
all right catherine very interesting
story thank you very much